wir sind immer noch in quarantäne und es
ist immer noch extrem langweilig apropos
langweilig jetzt ist ja dann aber zeit
denkst du dass wir zwei das heute noch
bestehen würden wie hat sich denn ihr
lehrer alltag jetzt verändert durch
corona ein positiver nebeneffekt des
ganzen ist dass ich jetzt hier in einer
jogginghose sitzen kann und meine
aufgabe überhaupt im pc den schuh dann
schicke ich habe mir die ich regelmäßig
voll machen aber da ist dann schon auch
alkohol drin oder jetzt gerade nicht ja
das gute im videochat ist ja dass man
die fahne vom lehrer nicht aushalten
muss das richtig ja das richtig geruchs
übertragen funktioniert würde ich sagen
sie manchmal zu den schülern im
unterricht dann auch das ist für mich
auch schon der sechs stream ja sowas
ehrlich ist das ist die sechste doofe
frage die ich jetzt gleich ein thema
beantworten muss und sagen sie dass
gerade zu mir hat zitieren sie gerade
sich also hier gerade so zu sagen ist
denn ein corona abi so viel wert wie ein
reguläres abi gute mal dass das geholt
habe ich noch viel wertvoller ist dafür
jetzt abitur machen die haben sich
verdient danach man kann auch danach
nicht die sau rauslassen man muss jetzt
die sau drinnen lassen hoffe dass die
schüler dieser auch zu hause lassen
können und da ihre wege finden um sich
abzureagieren
so gibt
und jetzt sprechen wir mit den leuten
die unter der jetzigen bildungssituation
am meisten leiden den youtube merken sie
dass die videos jetzt populärer werden
seit dem kontaktverbot noch populärer
bei eltern lehrerinnen lehrer
professoren also ist der unterschied
zwischen ihnen und einem richtigen
lehrer eigentlich nur dass man sie nicht
verstehen weil die internetverbindung in
deutschland so schlecht ist das ist das
ist auch ein punkt
das haben auch lehrer kritisch
zurückgeschrieben ein signifikanter teil
an schülerinnen schüler hat keinen
zugriff auf die tutorials ja wir sind
jetzt seit über einer woche in dieser
bude hier eingesperrt wir werden schlaff
blass und immer merkwürdiger also man
könnte uns schon mit echten matte fans
verwechseln
aber ihr habt ja noch zusätzlich zu
mathe auch tolle chance im sportprogramm
zu machen
[Musik]
sie sind bildungspolitischer sprecher
der spd nrw also bis nrw klang das ja
eigentlich sehr seriös genau der nach
historisch sehen wir nicht gerade beim
thema bildung dass der föderalismus
einfach nicht funktioniert gerade in der
krise auch das sind übrigens zu ich das
für unsäglich was die kultusminister
lage zu entscheiden haben dass da jeder
macht was er will und dass es nicht
zuerst abgestimmt worden ist das schadet
den kindern und ehrlich gesagt viele
eltern einfach kein verständnis dafür
dass es in jedem land eine andere
regelung gibt weil es ist immerhin noch
einen landen muss umziehen können es ist
ja einfacher von frankreich cluster
nordrhein westfalen zu wechseln als von
nordrhein-westfalen nach baden
württemberg ist das auch eine lösung
wenn man keinen bock aufs abi hat dass
man immer so von bundesland zu
bundesland umzieht bis das abi immer
weiter verschoben wird das ganze am
besten hält abheben oder ja dann kann
man mit 40 in bremen noch armee machen
das ist doch schön vielen dank herr ott
ja vielen dank bleiben sie gesund auf
ihre beziehung hat sich wieder ein
bisschen gekitzelt ja wieder ausschalten
miteinander
wir schalten jetzt einfach immer leute
zu wo wir uns einig sind dass wir noch
froh sind dass wir nicht mit denen
eingesperrt sind dann geht es da gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja it-service bruns ich spreche mit
irgendwie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung